ucrania y rusia están luchando casi a
calle en la ciudad de marjah por la
castigada urbe del sur y ucraniano que
se niega a rendirse a las tropas de
moscú y mientras en quiebra en la
capital de ucrania el ejército ucraniano
también asegura que está frenando el
avance de las tropas de moscú se trata
ésta de una zona estratégica para el
asedio de la capital de ucrania y
mientras en un momento en el que las
negociaciones se encuentran estancadas
el presidente de ucrania blogger
michelle es que sigue en las esperadas
búsqueda de nuevos mediadores que le
ayuden a resolver el conflicto bélico
que ya continúa en este país desde hace
tres semanas hoy se ha dirigido a otro
de los grandes países de la unión
europea esta vez a francia y al
parlamento de este país les ha dicho que
también país puede contribuir a poner
fin a la guerra en ucrania en un momento
en el que continuará llegará de más
denuncias de presuntos crímenes de
guerra cometidos por moscú durante sus
ataques en este país